robin d'angelo thanks so much for
joining me on the show tonight
your big best seller was white fragility
why it's so hard
for white people to talk about racism
your new book
is called nice racism how progressive
white people
perpetuate racial harm in the new book
you write quote i'm often asked why
white people should listen to a white
person on racism
so let's start there what is your answer
to that question why should they
well let me start by being very clear
that i do not believe
white people will ever understand what
we need to understand about racism if
we're not listening to black people and
other people of color
from a very early age they have to
understand my reality
and unfortunately i have not had to
understand theirs and
as an insider i do have a take an
understanding of it that they can't have
and we need all pieces of this puzzle at
the table
so early on in the book you relate a
self-critical anecdote about how you
once behaved at a dinner party with a
black couple i believe where afterwards
you'd realized you spent much of the
evening talking about
awful racist things some other people
you knew had done
is it your view that what you call such
racialized moves or covers in the book
by
quote unquote woke or progressive white
people that that is a common thing
and is it witting or unwitting in your
view
i think it's definitely a common theme i
have certainly gotten feedback across my
life about my enactments i have observed
countless
other enactments many many many black
people and other people of color have
written exhaustively about their
frustration
with this kind of uh well-meaning
implicit
kinds of racism i think it's unwitting
uh the impact is still
uh debilitating it's still powerful it
still
undermines uh you know in some ways
intentions are
less relevant than the impact of our
behavior
and robin in this trumpian era we now
live in we see more visible
maligned racism and ethnonationalism and
xenophobia in america
even a reactionary moral panic over
quote unquote critical race theory
um some people might wonder why you're
focusing on well-meaning
white progressives when those who are
not well-meaning as you say in the book
are growing and emboldened
and i would add violent you go into this
in the book can you explain to our
viewers why
here you know for three key reasons and
and i do not want to minimize the the
terror of that
growing movement and it is definitely
growing
but in my 20-plus years of being engaged
in these conversations
and research and observing and listening
uh there's a theme
that is expressed by black people and
other people of color and that is a
theme of exhaustion and that exhaustion
comes from the
more implicit forms the everyday forms
black people are not likely to be around
a white nationalist they're not likely
to be around people who explicitly
express
uh racial animus and in some ways uh
you know it's on the table it's easier
to protect oneself
from those forms of racism the
unconscious forms
are much more challenging and again
they're
much more daily another reason is that
i i see that white people like to take
as many exit points as we can and a
common one is as soon as you are
confronted with the reality of your own
complicity
you want to move to the more extreme
forms well what about
why i do not and could not
claim to represent every aspect of this
profoundly complex issue my focus is on
the more
implicit forms and that brings me to the
third reason
and that is that i am a classic
well-meaning white progressive
i know intimately both through my own
enactments
through feedback and through observation
those forms and that is what i focus on
they're harder to see
easier to deny and therefore we need
some help
you're right about the kind of harder to
see uh and easier to know i mean
i as a brown immigrant definitely would
say
it can be more frustrating dealing with
the kind of implicit racism from
well-intentioned people who don't
realize it
than from your explicit trump-like
figure who kind of i take for granted
that's a very fair point but consider
this something that strikes me about the
book nice racism
is that conservatives might actually
agree with a lot of your critique i
wonder whether you see
the weird overlap that i saw they see a
lot of white progresses for example out
on the streets
protesting and they say they're virtue
signaling they're trying to be woke
they're trying to outwork each other
they're trying to
romanticize minority cultures and you
kind of call that out too don't you in
the book
isn't that a lot of what you're
critiquing too
yes but the agendas are different and
what i would say is that the agenda
from the right is to protect the status
quo
the agenda on the left hopefully is to
challenge the status quo and systemic
racism is the status quo
you know within that work uh we want to
get this as right as we can
that's not completely possible but
we could do better we don't want to
inadvertently
reinforce the problem as we seek to
challenge it
one of the fiercest criticisms of your
work and it's not just from
conservatives but some liberals too and
to be fair you discuss it in the book
is the idea that you're perpetuating a
quote-unquote race essentialism that in
your view of the world
we can't escape our racial groups we're
locked into them we are
black white asian and that group
identity trumps whatever individual
non-race related characteristics we may
have
which some would say is a pretty
depressing view of the world
uh well i don't i don't think that
racism is going to end in my lifetime
and i think in some ways the kinds of
hopefulness that led to the complacency
we saw following the civil rights
movement
as it led us to this moment which looks
in a lot of ways pre-civil rights
but a lot of people of color even not
just forget white people for a second
a lot of people of color might say i
want to be able to have relationships
with people around me colleagues
students friends
without always having to worry about
which racial group i'm in
and if you read your stuff some people
come away thinking
you can only see the world you know
according to robin d'angelo
in racial groups i'm just wondering is
that how you see it or no
i think we could use much more
awareness of the reality of our racial
positions
they shape the way we see the world they
shape our experience in the world
there's not some objective universal
experience that we're all having
we could literally predict whether my
mother and i were going to survive my
birth based on the fact that my mother
and i are white
uh it is significant and we we don't
want to hold absolutely
everything at all times but we need to i
think we need to embrace it a little
more than than we have been
you spend a lot of the book um relating
some really dispiriting experiences from
racial sensitivity workshops that you
run or attend
i wonder is there any evidence out there
about those workshops and the
value that they deliver because there is
an argument on the left
that facilitating those kind of
workshops especially for corporations
for government organizations
you're giving them a racism get out of
jail free card almost they can say well
we paid for all this stuff look what
great employers we are
and i should point out for our viewers
last year a study found that u.s
companies spent eight
billion dollars uh on diversity and
inclusion and diversity consultants earn
somewhere
in total cumulatively around a billion
half a billion a year so i'm wondering
where's the evidence or data that you
have
because you're the expert on this i
wonder on those workshops on diversity
training because a lot of people are
cynical about that stuff so i'm just
wondering
how do we know it works well i don't
think it does work
if it's not sustained and consistent so
if it's a if it's a one-time thing a
check
the box kind of approach it's not going
to
uh keep you know keep going uh it has to
be
sustained and and i really would have us
question why we think there would be
a simple answer or solution we could
take this workshop or we should be able
to make this workshop
and figure out something as parentally
uh complex and deep and enduring and
highly adaptive as racism it is highly
adaptive
it it responds to challenges and it
keeps on keeping on
look where we are right now look at
voter suppression
yes look at actual laws enacted that say
you can't acknowledge that racism exists
or laws that say you can't teach the
history of the civil rights movement
uh this it's a it's a moving target in
so many ways and so anytime we think
one-size-fits-all it's gonna address it
we're gonna get
in trouble and i agree with a lot of
your analysis here totally see where
you're coming from and agree with a lot
of what you're saying
but at the same time i have to be honest
robin if i were asked to participate
in a seminar or workshop at work
and on racism and was separated out into
a room with only other people of color
while white people went into another
room i would find it kind of
uncomfortable and i know again you
discuss in the book that there's this
kind of
white panic i think you call it white
people panic when they're asked to
separate out and talk amongst themselves
but isn't it also a real danger that for
the sake of well-intentioned
a well-intentioned goal of reducing
racism we might be bringing back in
racial segregation by the back door
well what you're talking about is a is a
technique called affinity groups
it's actually a fairly advanced
technique it's not
common uh in kind of a mainstream
diversity training
but you know we we are positioned
differently within this construct we are
socialized differently
uh as a white person i have received
across my life and internalized the
message of
superiority uh and that's a very
different message than people of color
are given
and so there are aspects of this work
that we do need to do
separately among ourselves among other
people who share
our identities and without the pressure
of
making mistakes or or hurting other
people
you know there is not going to be
anything on a topic
as charged where investments are as deep
in both
challenging and protecting as the issue
of racism